I'm a friend that it's just going to a
friend to get some help that you need
Mary Donnelly of Block Island is an
inspiring figure for any number of
reasons in an America that's struggling
economically bailing out whole
industries and dead set on implementing
a government-run health care system we
can all learn a lot from her about how
best to help each other out the idea
that the Mary D fund could take care of
people it's an amazing privilege the 85
year old mother of seven and registered
nurse is the sole administrator of the
self named Mary defund she started the
fund 37 years ago as a charity for the
people of Block Island located about an
hour's ferry ride off the coast of Rhode
Island Block Island has a seasonal
economy that's strong in the summer
months but each year after the tourists
have vanished in the cold weather lays
in the residents struggled not just with
winter weather but a frozen economy too
through this fund Mary pays various
bills for Island residents who simply
don't have the money to provide for
themselves she's paid bills as big as
monthly mortgages and as small as a
ferry ticket to the mainland Donnelly
has helped about 30 percent of the
island's 1,000 year-round residents
doling out about $50,000 in age last
year alone she applies for grants from
private foundations and accepts
donations from individuals to help fund
the charity she doesn't take tax dollars
she runs a tight ship
she has three rules that you must follow
to get the Mary D fund to pay your bill
the stipulations were you had to live on
Block Island year oh you had to approach
me either with a letter or come here to
the office and then if I thought it was
needed I would pay the bill they have to
give the bill to me no money it's
ever-changing hand so they give me the
bill and if I think I can pay it I do if
I can pay part of it I do but whatever
it is I don't turn people away her help
always comes with free advice she wants
to make sure her fund does not enable
anyone to become too
they're losing their self-respect and I
don't think they think about that I tell
them they have to take a money
management course or something that I
can't do it you know I can't continue
doing this all the time because that's
what you're doing we're just enabling
them I was doing that for someone and I
told them they had to have money
management course and just within this
past couple of months I gave them a
small check which they returned and said
they realized people needed it more than
they did which was to me fantastic
because it was a big step forward for
them mary says that not having
government oversight has enabled her to
better manage where the money goes
helps ensure people will not get
depended upon the fund and offers a
sense of community I'm afraid it's just
going to a friend to get some help that
you need maybe the US government and the
rest of us too can learn a thing or two
from nurse Mary by helping people help
themselves and by insisting that Aid be
necessary in rare mary has given her
community much more than can ever be
recorded in a ledger